I think the most important technologies
that we have are those that we've had
for decades already one small example of
that would be oral rehydration therapy
which is a simple solution of sugar salt
and water which can save the lives of
severely dehydrated people people
dehydrated by cholera or intestinal
worms which has resulted in severe
diarrhea I've actually seen kids who
actually come back from death they're
they're literally hours from dying you
give them the simple solution in the
right quantity of oral rehydration
therapy and they're up running around
playing soccer so why isn't that being
used everywhere in the world the answer
is that the management the wherewithal
and the overall unity of focus on public
health does not currently exist in so
many countries instead they might be
trying more complex solutions
sophisticated antibiotics other
interventions such as intravenous drips
which can't be administered in all
resource-poor settings so it's really a
mixed perspective I think that there's a
lot to be said for new portable EKG s
and also electronic medical records but
overall I think first we've got to
figure out how do we roll out the
technologies that we've got a lot of
practice with which we know are
extremely effective and those are
technologies like insecticide treated
bed nets or combination therapy for
malaria or antiretroviral therapy for
hiv/aids these are all very basic
interventions which have been with us at
least a decade if not decades more than
that and yet they're not currently being
implemented across the board there's
actually some new vaccines which have
just come to market and are starting to
be used in developing countries
including a vaccine for pneumonia
pneumococcal vaccine which we just
piloted in Rwanda that's going to save
six thousand lives and it's just one
shot in the arm that kids need
periodically and they're going to be
good and it's going to end up saving
more lives than lots of
more sophisticated intervention